mit dem ergebnis hat keiner gerechnet
dass ich nicht ganz so viel gewonnen wie
in umfragen prognostiziert
sensationsergebnis julia lehmann hatte
mit guten ergebnissen gerechnet aber das
hatte man tatsächlich in dieser form
hier nicht wundert ihr euch auch
manchmal dass uns wahlergebnisse am ende
manchmal doch ziemlich überraschend sind
die meinungsumfragen wochen vorher
blueser unsinn
besonders die af.de schien in der
vergangenheit eine art blackbox zu sein
deren wahlergebnisse wohl eher nur
hellseher exakt vorhersagen konnten
hier kommen drei gründe warum die
forschungsinstitute bei der afd
besonders oft im dunkeln getappt sind
warum meinungsumfragen trotzdem kein
unsinn sind stattdessen immer mehr licht
ins dunkel bringen und warum
wahlumfragen weit mehr sind als die
antworten von befragten dazu werden wir
auch einer meinungsforscher denn auf den
zahn fühlen
los geht's vertraute ihr eigentlich
wahlumfragen verfolgt ihr sie habt ihr
vielleicht sogar selbst schon mal an
einer teilgenommen schreibt es mir gerne
unten in die kommentare
indem wir mal dieses beispiel hier 2016
in baden württemberg lag die afg gut
fünf wochen vor der landtagswahl in den
umfragen bei rund 11% im amtlichen
endergebnis der wahl kommt die afd dann
schließlich auf sage und schreibe 15,1
prozent
eine differenz von gut 4 prozentpunkten
das klingt jetzt nicht riesig ist
statistisch gesehen aber schon eine
hausnummer bei der landtagswahl im
gleichen jahr in rheinland pfalz wurde
die afg sogar um mehr als fünf
prozentpunkte unterschätzt warum schauen
wir uns dafür genauer an wie die
wahlumfragen eigentlich entstehen
die umfrageergebnisse des zdf
politbarometers basieren auf den
erhebungen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
dahinter steckt keine kleine zdf
arbeitsgruppe sondern das institut für
wahlanalysen und gesellschafts
beobachtung wie es sich selbst
bezeichnet
eines der renommiertesten institute für
umfragen in deutschland und es ist
sicher nicht überraschend aber für die
zahlen muss das institut erst mal leute
befragen
logisch und genau da stoßen wir auf die
erste große herausforderung
die zahlen sind natürlich umso
zuverlässiger die wahrheitsgemäße die
menschen antworten
das problem ist nur für menschen sagen
eben nicht immer die wahrheit bei den
umfragen spielt vor allem der social
design reality
er ist eine große rolle so viel was man
meinen kleinen exkurs in die soziologie
das ist die verzerrung durch soziale
erwünschtheit das konzept wurde schon
1972 von den soziologen derrick philips
und kevin kline sie entwickelt
vereinfacht gesagt personen tendieren
dazu anstatt die wahrheit zu sagen er
die antwort zu geben bei der sie
vermuten dass sie von der gesellschaft
air erwartet und akzeptiert wird der
effekt ging vielleicht hochtrabend aber
vielleicht habt ihr ähnliche erfahrungen
sogar selbst schon mal gemacht stellt
euch mal vor ihr diskutiert mit freunden
über eine serie um dies gerade einen
riesigen hype gibt alle freunde sind
sich einig die serie ist absolut genial
was sagt ihr denn wenn ihr die serie
überhaupt nicht toll findet naja man
schön vielleicht trotzdem ein weil man
nicht will dass die freunde komisch
gucken oder her man als außenseiter da
steht und so ähnlich dritte effekt bei
unzähligen sensiblen themen auch vor
allem bei wahlumfragen die systematische
verzerrung tritt dabei gerade bei
anhängern von parteien auf die weiter
von der mitte entfernt sind weiter links
oder weiter rechts zum beispiel auch bei
der fdp ist sicher aufgefallen
bei den anfangs erwähnten umfrage und
wahlergebnissen wurde die afg er
unterschätzt als überschätzt
und genau das kann eben auch von diesem
effekt kommen jetzt ist es ja nicht so
als würden meinungsforscherin und
meinungsforscher noch nie was vom social
design britta baier gehört haben
wieso wurden auch sie von früheren
wahlergebnissen der afb dann überrascht
hätte man das nicht irgendwie
berücksichtigen können also die r stehe
ich hier eine partei die hat ja schon
viele entwicklungen durchgemacht
zunächst als sie gegründet wurde war sie
also euro kritisch das heißt da war hat
sie zwar auch protest mit aufgefangen
aber sie hat jetzt sie weiß bei weitem
noch nicht so recht im parteienspektrum
zu verorten
wie das eben ganz wie das jetzt eher der
fall ist ja dann allerdings als die afg
eben nicht um sich eher richtung rechts
entwickelt habt dann mussten wir ja
erfahrungswerte annehmen die wir zwar
haben von anderen rechten parteien aber
die man halt doch das erste mal noch mal
so ein bisschen anpassen muss und diese
ersten waren die stattgefunden haben
nach dieser entwicklung des waren die
wahlen anfang 2016 in baden württemberg
rheinland pfalz und sachsen anhalt
und das war auch die phase wo wir die
af.de unterschätzt hatten sowohl in den
umfragen als auch in der prognose aber
dann haben wir darauf sehr sehr rasch
gelernt und seither gibt es eigentlich
dieses problem in der regel nicht mehr
bei den zwei bahnen baden württemberg
und in rheinland pfalz da haben wir die
als im vorteil in den umfragen ziemlich
gut getroffen man ist nie vor
überraschungen gefeit aber in der regel
hat es auch in den letzten jahren immer
ganz gut
na ja spannend dass bei diesem effekt so
schreibt es das institut für
wirtschaftsforschung in köln in seiner
untersuchung dass die wahl der afg in
ostdeutschland eher als zitat normal
angesehen wird als in westdeutschland
die leute geben denen ähnliche an dass
sie die afg gewählt haben falls euch
darüber noch genauer informieren wollt
alle quellen dazu findet ihr unten in
der infobox
jedenfalls die wahlergebnisse der afg zb
in sachsen oder thüringen konnten so
zwar nicht immer aber oft genauer
vorhergesehen werden
eine ähnliche herausforderung bei den
befragungen ist der sogenannte schweige
faktor
denn nicht nur was die leute sagen
sondern auch ob die leute überhaupt was
sagen kann zu einem problem werden zum
beispiel nach dem starken abschneiden
der fdp bei der bundestagswahl 2017
rückte der sogenannte schweige faktor in
den fokus der öffentlichkeit
gemeint ist statistisch gesehen sind afd
anhänger seltener bereit bei umfragen
mitzumachen
menschen mit extremeren einstellungen
tendieren eher dazu die teilnahme an
eine umfrage zu verweigern
die machen einfach nicht mit das ist
beispielsweise eine erkenntnis des
deutschen instituts für wirtschaft köln
die skepsis bei wlan extremeren parteien
gegenüber forschungsinstituten ist
größer und auch das kann das ergebnis
verzerren
habt ihr übrigens eine idee welche
parteianhänger überdurchschnittlich
auskunftsbereit sind es sind die grünen
er schweige faktor ist natürlich auch
nichts was völlig neu ist auch die
erfolge von republikanern und dvu in den
1990 er jahren wurden zunächst
unterschätzt damals wurde das sogenannte
bekenner problem als eine erklärung
angeführt aber solche erfahrungen können
meinungsforscher aufbauen
aber eben nur bis zu einem gewissen
punkt und da sind wir bei der dritten
herausforderung der großen unbekannten
die grundidee bei der wahlforschung ist
ja dass man eben nicht alle mehr als 60
millionen wahlberechtigten in
deutschland einzeln befragt wen sie
wählen würden dann würde schließlich
ständig bei irgendjemandem das handy
klingelt und man könnte auch diese
ganzen anrufe gar nicht bewerkstelligen
stattdessen trifft man eine auswahl gut
1000 personen und beim politbarometer
wenn man dann auf alle schließen kann
die umfrage also repräsentativ ist muss
man die tausend personen zufällig
auswählen
und weil man aber bekanntlich nicht alle
personen erreicht auch deshalb gibt es
tricks 17b der meinungsforscher trinken
jetzt ein bisschen klick beck mäßig es
sind natürlich ganz wissenschaftliche
methoden die daten die die befragten
angegeben haben landen bei der
statistikabteilung und werden dann
gewichtet manche sagen auch angepasst
geglättet oder korrigiert dazu ich habe
ja schon am anfang angedeutet wer denkt
bei wahlumfragen wie für das
politbarometer werden einfach nur ein
paar leute angerufen und deren
ergebnisse dann in tv veröffentlicht der
liegt da nicht so ganz richtig das
verfahren ist hochkomplex und jedes
umfrageinstitut hat auch sein eigenes
rezept mal angenommen bei einer umfrage
wurden nur halb so viele frauen befragt
wie der anteil in der bevölkerung ist
dann kommen deren ergebnis
zb doppelt ins ergebnis die
forschungsgruppe wahlen nennt es eine
erfahrungs basierte praktische anwendung
der wissenschaft weil man zum beispiel
bei saf de vela seltene auskunft geben
über ihre wahl vorlieben werden auch
diese ergebnisse gewichtet und
entsprechend hoch gerechnet man beugt
einer möglichen verzerrung schon vor
die frage ist aber natürlich die muss
man sie denn genau gewichten naja je
mehr erfahrungen die
meinungsforschungsinstitute mit einer
partei gesammelt haben dass du besser
gelingt ist das rauszufinden und
natürlich werde es im gegenzug schwerer
wenn eine neue partei in der deutschen
parteienlandschaft auftaucht so war das
auch bei der afd
doch durch genaue analysen gelingt es
den instituten mittlerweile immer
besseres richtige maß zu finden
mal angenommen man merkt bei der ersten
wahl dass nur ein drittel der späteren
wähler vorab zugegeben hat die partei
auch zu wählen
dann könnte das
meinungsforschungsinstitut bei der
nächsten wahl die daten derjenigen die
zu geben bei dieser parteien kreuz
gemacht zu haben einfach dreifach werden
simple dreisatz rechnung so zu sagen
vielleicht mathematik wird die klasse
naja ok in wahrheit ist es natürlich
deutlich komplizierter und vielleicht
fragt sich ja jetzt manch einer aber
wenn die dann die ergebnisse doch ändern
ist es dann überhaupt noch seriös nein
es ist sogar sehr wichtig dass man
verschiedene punkte mit berücksichtigt
wenn man eine aussage treffen will
was käme denn raus wenn am nächsten
sonntag wirklich bundestagswahl doch
klar ist je länger die ard existiert und
je mehr erfahrungen ist damit gibt desto
genauer wird die gewichtung ja natürlich
können wir in diesem video auch
grundsätzlich darüber sprechen warum die
wahlergebnisse bei allen parteien
schwierig vorherzusagen sind
warum warum fragen keine prognosen sind
denn die gibt's nur am wahltag wenn die
leute nach dem abstimmt befragt werden
wahlumfragen vorher zeigen nur die
stimmung am jeweiligen tag der umfrage
das ist sozusagen das kleingedruckte in
den umfragen agb bis zur wahl kann immer
noch eine ganze menge passieren
menschen können sich um entscheiden und
es gibt wie immer mehr unentschlossene
wechselwähler
ganz zu schweigen vom taktischen wählen
aber das ist ein eigenes thema das wir
mal in einem anderen video aufgreifen
können auf jeden fall nur weil die
ergebnisse von wahlumfragen vorab anders
sind als die späteren ergebnisse muss
das auch nicht heißen dass die
wahlumfragen zu dem zeitpunkt völlig
waren so das war das drei punkte die
natürlich alle damit zusammenhängen
warum die ergebnisse der afc in der
vergangenheit teilweise überraschend
waren
wenn anhänger einer bestimmten partei er
falsche oder gar keine antworten gegeben
bei wahlumfragen und eine schwierige
einzuschätzende gewichtung bei neueren
parteien später eine rolle
na ja und dann gibt es derzeit noch eine
große herausforderung bei den
meinungsforschern vielleicht ist das
auch eine herausforderung die dem ein
oder anderen eine schlaflose nacht
bereitet es ist die pandemie werden die
leute überhaupt zur wahl gehen werden
sie per briefwahl abstimmen und wer
stimmt dann überhaupt per briefwahl ab
da gibt es ja auch ganz unterschiedliche
einstellungen trotz aller unwägbarkeiten
durch immer mehr erfahrungen werden auch
die ergebnisse der afg immer weniger
überraschend und immer präziser in den
umfragen was übrigens auf jeden fall zu
100 prozent zutrifft es lohnt sich immer
bei umfragen hinzuschauen wie sie
entstehen
wie werden die leute ausgewählt ist das
überhaupt repräsentativ wenn ich euch
hier aufrufe abzustimmen ob ihr gerne
online video schaut ist es sicher
genauso wenig repräsentativ wie die
gleiche umfrage allein in einem
seniorenheim
wenn man bei beiden gruppen allein
überhaupt nicht auf die
gesamtbevölkerung schließen kann
manche umfragen entstehen mit
fragwürdigen methoden nicht selten für
möglichst spektakuläre ergebnisse oder
eine aussage die den eigenen interessen
dient also schaut immer genau hin
und wenn euch jemand von einer serie
erzählt die ihr total schlecht findet
natürlich keine vom zdf logisch 5 könnt
ihr auch ehrlich darauf antworten ja ich
hoffe das war für euch jetzt hier
transparent dargestellt wie gesagt mehr
informationen unten in der infobox und
hier leben hier findet ihr noch zwei
weitere spannende videos einmal die hat
die meinungsmacht richard david precht
zusammen mit wiso im gespräch und direkt
darunter ein video von mir von meinem
kanal mister rissen zwei wahlbetrug in
deutschland ist sowas möglich oder her
nicht schaut er gerne mal danke euch was
zuschauern und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]